if we don't have examples of women who
look like me
by the way my mother died when she was
76 my father died at 85 I'm 65 this year
it's going to end
sooner than later and I say sooner than
later not in a Macabre like oh my God
it's just the truth and so for me I
think the best thing is for women
particularly women to see people like me
because they go oh okay it's okay
you know what I am 14 years old this
girl is this girl at 4 20 in the morning
I was this girl I am this person all the
time you can be 14. and silly and look
like she looks
and realize that tick tock tick tock we
have stuff to do and that's why
charitable work is important and that's
why you know family Ruby Annie Chris
that my extended family my Sober Family
you know it's very important to me
I've had the most creative life in the
last year that I've had in my entire
life
at 64.
I have another children's book that I'm
publishing next year I'm in Haunted
Mansion I'm also trying to produce
things now I'm going to try to produce a
TV show based on the Scarpetta books uh
with Nicole Kidman next year for Amazon
this is my time to do my work because
I'm now having this opportunity to do it
I also by the way raise two kids and I'm
very I'm very happy that I did yogurt
commercials that make you poop for many
years to help me stay home and raise my
kids and be able to be available to my
children particularly my daughter Ruby
if you go back you will see that I was
going to retire at 40. there have been
many many many points where I said well
I don't think I'll ever make a movie
again I've said it for a long time
because I watched my parents
who both were monster Stars big big big
big big big big big stars
I watched them no longer get to do the
work that made them Stars
and I watched them just be famous people
who used to work
and it killed them and it's
heartbreaking and so I always felt like
I better get out before they no longer
ask me to come
I wanted to take by being their child
the great benefit to being the daughter
of famous people is that I saw what Fame
does to you and I'm not saying the bad
things I've seen the great parts of Fame
the access to the Arts the the worldwide
joy and and and and genuine love from
people all over the world wherever you
go yes but this downside is very very
tricky because you stop getting to do
that job
and so I've been saying all along oh I'm
not going to do it anymore oh no I'll
get out because I wanted to get out
before that moment where you're just
sitting there and you no longer get to
do the work and yet you're famous and
people go oh my God I love you hi oh my
God
and it was very important to me that I
do that and then what's been a miracle
is that every time I think I'm going to
do that then I get a job that then
transforms the next five years and
that's what's happened and so the fact
that these two pieces of work the bear
and everything everywhere all at once
are all happening right now
is just
I mean it's crazy it's crazy
it's absolutely beautiful and I I'm I
feel so privileged that I've been able
to do them that they asked me to to be a
part of these pieces of work you know
um
it's beautiful
[Music]